The double standard of our economy.
Destruction Minister Haarbeck has nothing left to beat I think what is
being denounced so loudly here is the coal phase-out and we have to stop
making energy with coal and we have to stop making gas and we have to
do everything on renewable energy because of the climate.
And coal-fired power plants are so climate-damaging.
Aha so.
Here it comes.
It is precisely these coal-fired power plants that are now supported by our
federal government and our Minister of Economic Destruction in Ukraine.
Because they need favorable energy and we don't and it doesn't matter if
we plague the climate case or if the climate is then destroyed,
because that doesn't cross the border,
because there is a different climate.
It's just like the climate in Norway,
it's nothing else like here.
And we have to do everything with renewable energy and everyone else around us.
They can do what they want,
because we have to save the world.
Aha and someone should explain to me how to balance this then.
Everything is banned here.
They even want to ban heating with wood.
Yes because of the climate.
And in Ukraine,
coal-fired power plants are now being used with what is being mined here.
That is done over it and is put there again so that
they have their coal-fired power plants.
And yes that exciting or.